since Stargate left our screens over a
decade ago we've often wondered where
some of the characters we knew and love
would have gone where would they be now
with the possibility of a new show
coming we can explore where certain
characters would have gone with their
careers where would they be located
today let's talk about Daniel Jackson
and where he could possibly be after all
this time
welcome to sciatric your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
thank you
if you're a regular side tracker you
know that we've spoken about the
possibility of Stargate coming back on
our screens within the next few years
and it's something that's really
exciting but something that we often
think about and we talk about on our
live streams quite often is if the show
did come back if Stargate was back on
our screens
the characters that we know and love
Jack O'Neill Daniel Jackson tilt
Samantha Carter Etc where would they be
10 years has passed since the show has
left our screens in fact it's been over
a decade and for about that time many
many possible things could have happened
today we're going to talk about where
Daniel Jackson could possibly have been
over the last 10 years and it's
something we have spoken about
previously on the channel I have had a
little bit of thought about this uh
recently and something that I've noticed
is that we've kind of been pegging
Daniel Jackson as being a new civilian
leader for a new Stargate program
something you may be aware of and you
may not be aware of is that Brad writes
scripts that well unfortunately no
longer seedle out of day would have seen
the Stargate program become public
knowledge now this was a really
interesting premise and we basically
surmised that Daniel Jackson would
probably be the best person to head up a
new Stargate program with a civilian
leader after all Daniel Jackson was
vital in the Inception of the Stargate
program he figured out that using the
glyphs in a specific order would
transport people from one point of space
into another via an act of Wormhole
without his work we probably would never
have opened the target to wabados and
all of sg1 SGA and SGU probably would
never have happened at least not in the
way that we would have known it because
we do know via alternate timelines that
without Daniel Jackson Samantha Carter
would have actually figured out a way to
dial the gate but in their reality they
also were a little bit too late and kind
of got destroyed by the Gould so it's
fair to say without Daniel Jackson the
Stargate program wouldn't be where it is
today and as I said we have basically
come up with the idea that Daniel
Jackson would be the perfect civilian
leader for a Stargate program that was
public knowledge the whole world knows
about the existence of the Stargate they
now know that aliens exist and we have
starships that travel intergalactically
into stellar and that we actually have
people halfway across the universe on
Destiny now if this target was public
knowledge would the public really want
the military involved in that or would
they rather have a civilian oversight I
think they probably would they probably
would want more civilian oversight on it
basically like what the ioa is because
now there's more at risk it's not just
the United States that are going through
the gate we'll have people from England
people from France people from Germany
people from all over the world would be
different teams going through the gate
and creating relationships with people
across the Galaxy now having one faction
of the military from Earth basically be
in charge of that probably wouldn't work
out as well as what they would probably
like to think so having a civilian
leader being Daniel Jackson I think it
would be a really really good idea
however now that we know that Brad right
script isn't actually going to happen
there's a possibility that the Stargate
program will still remain a secret in
that eventuality I have a theory of
where Daniel Jackson would possibly be
and I can't believe I haven't thought
about this before because honestly this
is the most obvious location for Daniel
Jackson to go
it's Atlantis now we know at the end of
Stargate Atlantis that the ship the city
ship actually landed in San Francisco
Bay and is currently on Earth but the
threat of the race still hasn't
disappeared so they would have no doubt
gone back to Pegasus at some point
they're probably going to need a leader
because Richard Woolsey Samantha Carter
probably aren't going to want to do it
forever but the one person who wanted to
go to Atlantis Australia for an extended
period of time but never got the
opportunity to was Daniel Jackson
in fact I think the only time he went
there was during season 10 of Stargate
sg1
and he even makes a comment about it
being that he's waited so long to get
here but obviously he was part of sg1
and now 10 years has passed maybe he's
no longer a part of sg1 and he's the
leader of the Atlantis Expedition The
Wraith could possibly have now been
wiped out the war with them is over
maybe there was a drug created to help
The Wraith not be so dependent on taking
human life and feeding off the life
force of others and now there is some
sort of peace treaty with them or maybe
they have all just been destroyed who
knows but the best person to have led
the Atlantis Expedition would have
always been should the stars have
aligned Daniel Jackson but unfortunately
he never managed to get there
10 years has passed maybe he's finally
there something that we have to remember
about Daniel Jackson he is an
archaeologist he is an Explorer and he
loves to study ancient cultures he has a
very keen interest in the Ancients
having been an ascended himself he set
more interactions with the Ancients
themselves than anyone else in the
Stargate franchise and with with all
those interactions comes a lot of
understanding about their ways and their
culture and Atlantis being a treasure
Trove of information hidden labs and
secret technology he would be the
perfect person to oversee that
expedition Atlantis could possibly now
be back on Earth as I said before The
Wraith could have been destroyed wiped
out there could be a peace treaty
whatever the case may be they may have
decided to bring Atlantis to Earth for
further study but they're still going to
need a leader for the base even if that
scenario doesn't quite work out the way
I've explained it it could possibly be
that the Stargate program is public
knowledge but the Stargate program is
now located and based out of Atlantis
helmed by Daniel Jackson I don't know
these are just my thoughts on where I
think Daniel Jackson would have
eventually gone to after he'd left SG-1
for me moving to Atlantis is the next
logical step for him and if the target
program was public knowledge and
everyone knew about Atlantis and they
based the Stargate program out of
Atlantis he would be the best person I
think to run that program because he'd
be in the location that he wanted to be
in all this time
and he would be basically overseeing the
exploration of the Galaxy it would also
be really really good at diplomatic
relations because he's always been that
kind of person who
even when
things look dire when peace talks or
diplomatic relations look like they were
going to break down or anything like
that he was always the voice of reason
in many situations and I think that's
really good quality for a leader
unfortunately he never became a leader
of any sort when we were watching
Stargate sg1 in fact when we were
watching Stargate University kind of
became an earth cop kind of thing where
he would go out on Earth to try and
locate like the Lucian Alliance and
things like that but and maybe he was
harming his own division there as a
leader but we never really got
confirmation on that I think as I've
said the next logical step for Daniel
Jackson would always have been to go to
Atlantis maybe he went there as a
consultant for a little while but
eventually moved up the ranks and he
became the leader it's the most logical
thing I can think of and in terms of
character progression and where that
character wanted to be with his career
and with his studies and everything that
just aligns with him Atlantis is the
place for for him but what do you think
let me know in the comment section down
below if you agree with me if you have
any other suggestions about where Daniel
Jackson could possibly be
and we'll talk about in the comments
section
whilst you're down there hit subscribe
and press the Bell notification so you
don't miss a single video also consider
becoming a fully fantasized tracker by
hitting the join button down below thank
you so much for watching my name is Matt
and I will see you
next week
[Music]